hawky no no no hockey no hockey no no no
no hockey yes thank you hockey my name
is Emma laser now let's get to it
the origin of the word hockey is unknown
the first confirmed use of word hockey
was in 1773 Howard there are some
scholars who dispute this and say that
the word hockey was used far before
death
Harry nobody really knows the true
origin of the word one possible
explanation may be that the word hockey
is derived from the middle French word
okay meaning curved stick most likely
referring to the hockey stick used for
the game ball and stick games or proto
hockey games could be found all around
Europe dating back as far as 2,000 years
ago from Greece to Russia from Sweden to
Britain each place had its own form of
some sort of a stick and ball game the
Dutch British and Russians came closest
to
imitating today's modern hockey however
all of these proto hockey games were
quite a bit different from today's
hockey the Dutch ball and stick game
resembled more golf on iced and hockey
and the Russian game called bandy was
played with no ice skates and round ball
instead of a puck the British game of
hare Lee had some similarities to
today's hockey Hart was played on a
field instead upon pice Howard a
Scottish game of shinty resembled the
rules of today's hockey the closest this
game was predominantly played during the
winter holidays when entire villages
live together to watch the game of
shinty it was from shinty that hockey
got its stick shapes checking the
ability to use both sides of the stake
and being able to play the puck in the
air in the end none of these games
evolved directly into hockey but they
all paved the way for many ball and
stick games played today like field
hockey floorball floor hockey bandy
adductor for the creation of hockey
itself it took the colonisation of
Canada by Russians British and Dutch
immigrants to bring all these proto
hockey games together it was during this
time that the word shinty got
abbreviated to shinny and get merged
with bandy and Hurley and started to be
played on ice with ice skates however
even though resembling water hockey
there were still many different games of
shinny being played all around Canada
some still used the ball some it would
impart some had nine players per team on
the ice
had more and some headless it took one
man James Crichton to be inspired by the
game of rugby and apply it to shinny
creating his own version of shinny where
chicking was allowed and passing could
be only done backwards he rented out the
Victoria skating rink in Montreal and
with his friends played the first
official organized game of hockey in
1875 from there the game slowly took off
with newspapers printing about this new
and exciting game and with the
tournament being held at the Montreal
Winter Carnival hockey was still mostly
played by Montreal gentlemen of McGill
University as many people didn't have
time to spend for playing in sports
power the game became very popular with
the younger generation who had the time
to spend the long winters combined with
the cheap strap on shoe skates and
makeshift sticks meant that the game was
accessible and easy to pick up for kids
and so these kids were the children of
Frederick Arthur Stanley the governor of
Canada his kids were so infatuated with
hockey that when they were all dirt and
were playing in a pro hockey league they
controlled their father to pay $50 for
the creation of the Stanley Cup the cup
that for generations will be thought
over by hockey teams all around North
America it was during the end of the
19th century when the rule of only
passing backwards was abandoned and the
rules for hockey became more
standardized due to the plethora of new
Hockey League's emerging all around
Canada a particularly important one was
the National Hockey Association which
later on evolved into the NHL we have
today during the 20th century the game
spread all the way to Europe more
precisely Sweden Finland Czechoslovakia
and the Soviet Union each of these
countries had their own version of proto
hockey most notably bandy how was the
arrival of hockey many players quickly
shifted to the new game and so the power
struggle between the fourth hockey
nations in Europe was for defense weeds
and czechoslovaks we're the first ones
to pick up on modern hockey starting
around the world war one era the Soviet
Union would join the world of hockey
later after World War two to show the
world through hockey that communism is a
superior option and even though this may
seem like a crazy idea it wasn't only
through hockey that the Soviets were
trying to do this today's hockey had a
very complicated history there was no
one events that created Hockey Britain
wasn't
Oh Lucien over time they gave us the
hockey world that we have today in the
end hockey is in a game that was shaved
by other games or politics but it is a
game that was shaped by the people who
played it who enjoyed it the people that
believed that this game had a future
so this September when you see your team
out there on the ice representing your
country remember the history the
electric duck one great moment because
great moments are born from great
opportunity now go up there and take it
you